so i'm going to tell you today
about a way of looking at the world that
i think is substantially different from
the way that most people look at the
world
and the way i want to tell you about
looking at the world today
is i think more inclusive than a
standard sort of materialist view like
the standard scientific view of the
world of course is that
it's made up of familiar objects and
that the world is in essence a material
place
but there's some very potent limitations
of that
viewpoint despite the fact that it's
given us tremendous power
and the limitations are essentially as
follows
the essential materialist view
can't tell us anything about
consciousness which is probably the
primary fact of experience
neuroscientists in recent years mostly
in the last decade have been trying to
crack the problem of consciousness
and they have absolutely made no
progress
they've tried to associate consciousness
with neuronal activity but that seems to
be an incomplete answer because there's
many forms of neuronal activity in the
brain
that aren't accompanied by consciousness
at all
not only do neuroscientists understand
virtually nothing about consciousness
they can't even really figure out what
its function is they can't understand
why
our brains would go to so much effort to
make us aware
of things when it isn't clear at all
that awareness is necessary for life
especially given that there are many
life forms on the planet that don't seem
to be aware at all
the standard materialist view is also
insufficient many other ways it's
insufficient philosophically i think as
you probably all know
because a conception that portrays the
world as made up of objects is in some
really fundamental way
dead right it doesn't seem to have a
place in it for human beings or a place
in it for meaning or
a mode whereby you might be able to
conceptualize the real existence of
something like an emotion or a dream or
a motivation
all phenomena which are just as
mysterious to neuroscientists and to
scientists in general
as consciousness now the problem with
this seems to be
mostly experiential if you have to ask
people what they know more than anything
else
they know number one that they're
conscious they know number two
that their internal experiential life
is composed of emotions and motivational
states which
although not rational in essential
structure are so
real and relevant that virtually
everything that people do
is predicated on them so our current
viewpoint
despite its ability to give us
tremendous technological power
seems to eradicate from formal
consideration
many many essential experiences that are
vital to life in fact even perhaps
primary
now i'm going to suggest to you today
that there's an alternative viewpoint
and i i think also it's one
that although you may be hearing about
it formally for the first time is also
something that you know
unbelievably deeply how thousands of
years ago
plato proposed that all knowledge was
remembering
of course we don't believe that today
because we believe we gather knowledge
as a consequence of contact with the
world
but you'll see today that the knowledge
that i'm going to share with you
will strike a deep court of remembering
and it's because everything that you've
done throughout your life is
in one way or another predicated on what
i'm going to tell you today
i'm going to demonstrate this in a
peculiar way i think because i'm going
to start by telling you a story
and the reason i'm going to do that is
because models of the world that include
phenomena like consciousness and
emotions and motivations and actions and
interactions
are generally portrayed formally in
stories
and not in scientific theories and it
does turn out to be that stories
themselves have an identifiable
structure even a grammar
that makes them comprehensible
furthermore it turns out that even the
simplest
stories especially if they're elegantly
constructed have an unbelievably
profound underlying meaning and you can
frequently see this
most particularly in children's stories
so i remember i showed my son
when he was four years old the disney
movie pinocchio which
on the surface of it is a very strange
tale right it's a
wooden puppet who wants to become real
so he has to rescue his father from the
belly of a whale
a structure that could by no means be
considered rational
that is in fact so surprising and
unexpected that it's remarkable to
imagine that grown men and women
including children can sit in a movie
theater
and watch a story like that unfold
without ever thinking for a second
that it's absolutely peculiar that they
can be taken in by such a tale
and regard it experientially as real
pinocchio is a deep deep story it has
echoes that go back
three or four thousand years to the
earliest stories that we know and it's
so rich with information
that a child can watch it over and over
and over and over
i think my son watched pinocchio 30
times
why well it's either because a child
can't tell the difference between
fantasy and reality or it's because
there's something to those stories
that's much more potent than we actually
consciously understand
it's kind of interesting too you know if
you go to a if you've got a video rental
establishment you'll find that in the
top 10 highest grossing movies of all
time
are four disney movies that are animated
fairy tales essentially retelling of
mythological stories
they strike a deep chord why
well shakespeare was of course a great
literary figure
said it perhaps better than anyone else
has
which is not surprising because he said
many things better than anyone else has
he said all the world's a stage and all
the men and women merely players they
have their exits and their entrances
and one man in his time plays many parts
and so
following from that you can imagine that
a story is no more about the props
in the world then a play that you go see
is about the props on the stage
drama is about the manner in which
people actually exist the emotions that
they feel the motivational states they
encounter
the problems they have to solve when
they interact with each other and the
play is the thing from that particular
perspective in which we can capture
those aspects of our experience that are
not only real but essentially human
i'm going to tell you a little story to
begin this off with it's a kid's story
written for
children of about four years of age but
it's very very elegant
i tried to cut it down for this talk but
i found i couldn't because it was so
well edited that every single piece of
it
had to fit in to make the story complete
and i'm going to show you first
the structure of the story now this is a
very
useful diagram in many ways it's very
simple
basically it says this whenever you're
doing anything
you inhabit a bounded world now you know
like for example you're sitting here in
this lecture there's things you're
paying attention to and things you're
not if i took
most of you out of this room right now
and asked you
definitively what color the rug was you
wouldn't know or what color your chair
was for example or what the person next
to you was wearing unless that person
happens to be your husband or your wife
you wouldn't remember any of those
things and the reason for that is when
you're in a situation like this and
you're attending to a speaker
most of the occurrences that are
unfolding around you are irrelevant you
don't store them you only focus on
certain things well how do you decide
what to focus on given that there's a
virtually unlimited number of things to
pay attention to
well you have to conceive of yourself as
being somewhere
always and you have to conceive of
yourself as going somewhere so you could
say in
in a real sense the world you inhabit is
a journey it's a journey from
point a to point b a journey from what
is to what should be
a journey from the place you are which
is insufficient in some important
manner to a place that in some important
manner is going to be better
a standard story has exactly that
structure child comes home and you say
well what
happened to you today on the way to
school setting up the little narrative
structure and the child to unfold the
sequence of events that he encountered
if the story's
more interesting than just a recount
of exactly what happened to him it
usually involves the encounter with
something unexpected on the way to point
b
and a description of the manner in which
that encounter with the unexpected was
resolved
typical story now why would you want to
know that why would you want to listen
to it
well it's because on your journey from
point a to point b
all sorts of unexpected things always
happen and
if someone else has encountered
something unexpected and conjured up a
decent solution to it
it could well be worth your time to
listen
well maybe there's a pattern to
encountering unexpected things maybe
there's a
proper way to encounter the unexpected
maybe
it's the case that in our collective
wisdom as human beings we've
gathered up representations of ways
to encounter the unexpected that we put
forth in our stories
how should you face what you don't
understand
well now i'm going to tell you this
story it's written for four-year-old
kids
but i want you to take a look at it for
a moment from a different perspective
and see if you can imagine exactly what
it is that it's saying
there's no such thing as a dragon
well we all know that right a dragon is
a fictitious creature
reptilian terrible lives forever
breathes fire hoards gold
strange combination of attributes why
would something terrible
and ancient hold a treasure
billy bixby was rather surprised when he
woke up one morning
and found a dragon in his room it was a
small dragon about the size of a kitten
the dragon wagged its tail happily
when billy patted its head
it's interesting you know in chinese
mythology
dragon is a positive figure in
european mythology the dragon is
something to face in combat
and destroy or something to face in
combat and build something
out of the pieces left over from the
dragon
billy went downstairs to tell his mother
there's no such thing as a dragon said
billy's mother
and she said it like she meant it
remember once my daughter had a
nightmare she was about four
this was at the time when she first
started to notice graffiti and litter
and both graffiti and litter bothered
her she couldn't understand the
motivations behind the graffiti artist
and she didn't like the fact that there
was litter cluttering up the world's
order
and the reason she got sensitive to that
as a child was because
children are really really dependent on
order right i mean and the reason for
that is that their realm of competence
is rather restricted so
they like to see things messed up so
little kids for example
they're not happy with you if you play a
game with them and then mess around with
the rules of the game they don't like
that at all they think that that's
immoral activity to shake up the
structure of the game
well anyways while she was pondering all
this she
came into our bedroom one night and said
dad i had a nightmare
now we all know right nightmares aren't
real just like dragons
dreams aren't real of course which
raises the question of why in the world
you'd bother having them
six or seven hours a night every single
day of your life
and why they're a recognized feature of
animal behavior all the way down to the
amphibian level
she said i dreamt that there was a clear
flowing stream
but in the stream there was all sorts of
garbage and it scared me and bothered me
so much i woke up so i told her look
close your eyes and imagine the stream
it's full of garbage
what should you do about it she said
well i should take the garbage out of
the stream i said all right so
picture the stream picture yourself
cleaning the garbage out of it
she calmed down and went back to sleep
why well because dreams concentrate on
threat we know that they present
threats to you threats you haven't been
able to deal with well
there's a part of your brain that tracks
threats and it's not really all that
smart in some ways all it does is say
look here's the problem and it's waiting
for the rest of your brain to conjure up
some solution to that problem
and if it doesn't conjure up a solution
then it just presents the problem
over and over and over and over and over
so people who have post-traumatic stress
disorder for example who've been
really upset by their contact with
something unexpected dream about the
same tragedy
forever until they solve it and they
solve it by
facing it and living it over and over
voluntarily so you might think right off
the bat from listening to that little
story that
suggesting to your four-year-old
daughter who's just had a nightmare that
her fears aren't real and that the dream
representation of them isn't real
because it's not tangible like a table
might not really be the best approach to
the problem
so you see billy he's pretty much got it
right right off the bat right
the dragon wagged his tail happily when
billy patted its head
billy went downstairs to tell his mother
there's no such thing as a dragon
said billy's mother and she said it like
she meant it
so there's a dragon in this house now
the next thing you might wonder is
how often have you actually gone into a
house where there's a dragon
my guess is if you don't take this
particularly specifically and allow
yourself to use your imagination and to
think metaphorically for a moment
you've all encountered dozens of houses
that were filled right to the rafters
with various dragons
all of which were being studiously
ignored by the people who inhabited the
house billy went back to his room and
began to dress the dragon came close to
billy
in a friendly manner and wagged its tail
but billy didn't pat it
if there's no such thing as something
it's silly to pat it on the head
billy washed his face and hands and went
down to breakfast the dragon went along
it was bigger now almost the size of a
dog
billy sat down at the table the dragon
sat down
on the table this sort of thing was not
usually permitted but there wasn't much
billy's mother could do about it
she'd already said there was no such
thing as a dragon and if there's no such
thing
you can't tell it to get down off the
table
sometimes i sit with friends of mine who
have very young children
to eat say and the children two or three
years old
don't sit at the table they sit on the
table or they run around the table or
they run around the table and pull
things off the table
or they run around the house and pull
things off all the shelves in the house
and keep their parents so busy chasing
them around that they have no time
whatsoever to interact as adults
well you have to wonder under those
circumstances whether you're dealing
with a child
or a dragon so to speak and you also
might wonder whether or not
the dragon is large and unruly
precisely because the parents are
completely unwilling to admit that it
actually exists
mother made some pancakes for billy
but the dragon ate them all mother made
some more but the dragon ate those two
mother kept making pancakes until she
ran out of batter
billy only got one of them but he said
that's all he really wanted anyway
one time
an acquaintance of ours in boston
brought their son over to be babysat at
our house and
his nanny had just been in a car
accident so he was being shunted from
house to house while his parents went
off to work
and uh he didn't have very good
reputation this kid he was about four
and uh
he came over to our house and with his
mother in the morning and she dropped
him off and she said
well he probably won't eat all day but
that's all right and i thought
no he's four if he doesn't eat all day
that's not all right right because kids
if they don't eat they're
basically horrible right if they don't
sleep and they don't eat they're
horrible so
it isn't all right that he doesn't eat
so then you think well maybe there's
some sort of dragon associated with this
child that happens to be interfering
perhaps with his ability to eat so i
came back at noon my wife had taken care
of the children
that day and i walked in the house and
the other four or five kids that we had
in the house were off playing and this
little kid was
standing in the corner like really
isolated and looking
you know upset fundamentally so i went
over and i poked him a bunch because
generally if you poke a kid a little bit
you know well they'll go like this you
know they'll sort of back off but
sooner or later you can crack them and
they'll smile and then they'll play not
this kid boy there's no bloody way he's
going to play with me and that was
that like he'd already learned that
adults should either be ignored or that
they were trouble
and he wasn't going to let any adult
into his little world so
there was absolutely a dragon associated
with that little boy and it was eating
all his pancakes
billy went upstairs to brush his teeth
mother started clearing the table
the dragon who was quite as big as
mother by this time made himself
comfortable on the whole rug and went to
sleep
i really like this one by the time billy
came back downstairs the dragon had
grown so much he filled the hall
billy had to go around by way of the
living room to get to where his mother
was
i didn't know dragons grew so fast said
billy there's no such thing as a dragon
said mother firmly
cleaning the downstairs took mother all
morning
what with the dragon in the way and
having to climb in and out of windows to
get from room to room
so you know you think back in your own
experience
when you've gone to a house where
there's a dragon hiding underneath the
living room rug and nobody's saying
anything about it and then you think how
long does it take to get something
absolutely simple done
in a house that's absolutely jammed to
the rafters with unfinished business
forever right organizing people in a
household like that to even do something
as simple as go out for breakfast in the
morning or even perhaps to make a meal
is virtually impossible
well because there's something going on
in the household
that has been studiously ignored for a
very long time
and has grown so large as a consequence
that it occupies the whole domain
by noon the dragon filled the house its
head hung out the front door its tail
hung out the back door and there wasn't
a room in the house
that didn't have some part of the dragon
in it
when the dragon awoke from his nap he
was hungry the bakery truck went by the
smell of fresh bread was more than the
dragon could resist
he ran down the street after the bakery
truck the house went along of course
like the shell on a snail
[Applause]
the mailman was just coming up the path
with some mail for the bixbies when
their house rushed past him
and headed down the street he chased the
bixby's house for a few blocks but he
but he couldn't catch it
when mr bixby came home for lunch the
first thing he noticed was that his
house was gone
luckily one of the neighbors was able to
tell him which way it went
you know that sort of thing happens to
people not infrequently too right
they're not really looking around much
at what's going on and
they come home from work one day and
their house is gone
and what does that mean well maybe their
children have become completely
alienated from them or maybe their wife
has decided
suddenly but of course not so suddenly
to leave
why well according to this story it's
because
something ignored was growing in the
house
mr bixby got in his car and went looking
for the house he studied all the houses
as he drove along
finally he saw one that looked familiar
billy and mrs bixby were waving from an
upstairs window
you know in in the 1890s in india when a
house was being built
the local priest equivalent to the
priest
would come by to set the foundation
stone and when he set the foundation
stone he'd take a big
spike and drove it into the ground and
the reason he drove it into the ground
at the
place where the foundation was going to
be laid was to keep the great dragon
that is underneath the earth
firmly pinned down by its head so it
couldn't move and shake the house to
bits
what does that mean well it means the
same thing that's meant in the new
testament when you're told not to build
your house on a foundation of sand
right it doesn't matter how good the
house is or how
well constructed it is or how rich it is
if the foundation is made out of sand
or if it rests on top of a dragon
there's nothing in that household that's
ever going to be accomplished that's
positive
and the wealth the display that the
house might consist of is nothing but a
sham
mr bixby climbed over the dragon's head
onto the porch roof and through the
upstairs window
how did this happen mr bixby asked
it was the dragon said billy there's no
such thing
mother started to say there is a dragon
billy insisted a very big dragon
and billy patted the dragon on the head
the dragon wagged its tail happily then
even faster than it had grown
the dragon started getting smaller
soon it was kitten size again
i don't mind dragons this size said
mother
why did it have to grow so big i'm not
sure said billy but i think it just
wanted to be noticed
so the first thing you might think about
is just what happens if you don't pay a
bill
like really don't pay it right i mean
when it first comes in it's only the
size of a kitten
but if you leave it alone for two or
three years it pretty much grows into a
full-fledged dragon
why well because things that you ignore
have a life of their own complex life
like a bill
bill's attached to a whole industrial
complex right
one of whose major functions is to make
sure that you pay the bill
and if you don't pay the bill then you
immediately find out what it's connected
to it's connected to something immense
and very troublesome and if you allow
the full force of that thing to manifest
itself it's not pretty
so one lesson from this story is that
if something's nagging at you
just a bit it's probably better to deal
with it before it turns into a
full-fledged dragon
and then you might think well what if
it's already a full-fledged dragon right
i mean then what's your option
is there nothing left but to run away
and so then i can tell you what we know
from 50 years of studying the outcome of
clinical psychological interventions
so let's take an extreme case right
let's say something truly terrible has
happened to you
and as a consequence of that you're in
shock post-traumatic shock
which is a condition that's sufficiently
serious
to damage your brain over time it's not
only a psychological disorder it's a
physical disorder
if you're really stressed your cortisol
levels shoot up and if your cortisol
levels shoot up
that cortisol in high doses is a
neurotoxin starts to damage your brain
so let's take a very extreme case and
imagine that you've been
violently sexually assaulted and as a
consequence of that you're in
post-traumatic shock how do you get
cured so that means you can't really go
outside you certainly can't encounter
anything that's associated with the
event
your sense of integrity and personal
safety has been completely destroyed
is there any way you can get back on
your feet now there's a woman named edna
foa in new york
i think one of the world's top clinical
psychologists and she's been dealing
with women who have post-traumatic
stress disorder for decades
and she's found a treatment
that works and the treatment is this
she has the women relive the event in as
much
detail as possible over and over in
their imagination with the accompanying
emotion
and she's found because she's done
physiological measurements on her
clients
that those women that allow themselves
to get the most fully upset as a
consequence of the reliving
get better faster and stay better longer
the clinical evidence is absolutely
clear when you take someone to therapy
you're basically doing
two things to them well three you allow
them to confess what's wrong with them
because it's really useful to actually
say what it is that's bothering you
makes it clear and distinct
you help the person get their story
straight because you have to have your
story straight right
you have to know where you're coming
from and you have to know where you're
going because otherwise there's no
structure for your life
and the third thing is if your path
from point a to b is being blocked by
something that you're afraid of you
better learn to confront it because if
you don't
it will grow and expand until it turns
into the kind of dragon that occupies
your whole house
this is another representation of a
story that's a simple story i think it's
one that's
really most applicable to children at
there are aspects of it that are most
applicable to children sexual desire one
obviously isn't
it's a map of motivation it basically
says this and and it's easy to
understand if you think
go to a movie it doesn't matter what
country it's made there's certain
things that always happen right like two
broad classes of
fiction adventure and romance what's an
adventure
to go to new lands and discover
something new and become transformed as
a consequence what's a romance
to meet another person who's certainly
as complicated as anything you could
meet
on an adventure and again to be
transformed as a consequence of the
contact
to fundamental plots why why are there
fundamental plots
and why can we understand them without
them being explained to us well it's
because
fundamentally we're all very very
similar we have
a finite set of basic needs so for
example
hot people would rather be cool thirsty
people would rather have water
hungry people would rather eat and these
motivations color what we conceive of as
our ultimate destiny so in the old
testament for example
an agrarian community often hungry
paradise was construed as the land of
milk and honey
well why well milk is high in fat and
honey is high in glucose and if you're
hungry really hungry
there's nothing you want more than fat
and sugar
affiliative desire we like to be around
other people sexual desire
a fundamental sub element of a romantic
plot these underlying motivational
systems of ours
set us up bounded worlds
within which we live so for example if
you fall in love with someone
and you construe your destiny as being
with them
any indication that they're pleased with
you is going to produce a rush of
positive emotion
why because our emotional systems are
set up so that any sign
that we're moving towards our goal is
responded to with a rush of positive
emotion
and conversely a frown from the person
that you love
especially in the initial ages of
initial stages of a romance
is met with a flood of negative affect
why because anything that stops us
on the path that we've chosen produces
negative emotion
that's how we're set up and our
emotional systems are actually quite
straightforward
we posit a goal the thing about people
is that we can posit virtually anything
as a goal
that's one of the things that
distinguishes us from animals so we can
all be thrilled to death when our
favorite soccer team
scores a goal because we participate in
what they're doing
the same way we participate in watching
a protagonist
on a movie or in a book we can feel it
we embody it we even know now that the
neural systems
that i utilize to watch a movie
involve the same neural systems that the
actor is utilizing acting out the part
so when you say you understand someone
else what you mean is
your body is set to do exactly the same
thing their body is
and your emotional systems are locked on
exactly the same way theirs are so when
they experience something and you're
watching it
you experience an echo of it and that's
what understanding means
and it turns out as well that those
neural systems that allow us to
embody someone else and to imitate them
are right underneath the structures that
we've evolved
to use for language and what that
indicates is that mostly what we use
language for
is to tell stories to tell stories about
the way that people
act so that we can derive information
not about what the world's made of
because we don't really care about that
some fundamental way but instead how
should we act
that's the fundamental question how
should we act
now if you go see a movie about a thug
the message there is given that the thug
generally comes to not so good end
don't act like a thug right interesting
though it might be
compelling as a lifestyle at least
sufficiently compelling so you'll watch
it
it's not a good long-term strategy
what is a good long-term strategy
you know we've been collecting stories
as people for we don't know how long
really we don't know hundred thousand
years maybe there's been creatures like
us
indistinguishable from us for a hundred
thousand years and we know that
societies that appear to be more or less
as archaic as those
old societies tell stories have rituals
have mythology
we have ancient written stories like the
anumilish which is a sumerian story the
oldest written story we have
four thousand years old based on a oral
tradition that's probably 20
000 years older than that we've been
collecting stories for a long long time
what do they mean what are they good for
well imagine this you know you tell a
story to your husband or your wife hey
but something interesting that you saw
right well then imagine that you could
collect a thousand
of the most interesting stories and then
imagine that you were some kind of
literary genius like
like shakespeare and you could take
those thousand interesting stories
and boil them down to a hundred really
interesting stories
and then imagine that you had ten
thousand years to gather up those
hundred
most interesting stories and average
them and you could come out with one
perfect story the best story the most
interesting story that you could
possibly tell
well that's what a myth is it's the most
interesting story you can possibly tell
and just as this little story that i
just told you had an underlying
mythological structure
virtually every story you ever see has
such a structure
that's why it's compelling to you and
when you meet someone who's charismatic
or who holds your attention
or who you're interested in the
probability that they're acting out a
mythological fragment
is very very high and that's why it is
that your attention is captivated by the
what's the world like from this
perspective well look you know you're
all sitting in this room you think if i
took you out of here how would you
describe it
well you'd say it was full of chairs
there was a table lights
well why would you pick that level of
resolution like why wouldn't you say
well
you know the average ceiling tile had
about 15
000 dots on it doesn't seem like a
relevant
data point right you say the same thing
about the rug there's no nothing
stopping you
from counting the number of stains or
the number of red spots or
the way the light plays off your
partner's shirt or the shine on your
shoes and if you were an artist say and
trying to make a representation of this
room you'd concentrate on aspects that
were completely different from those
that you're concentrating on now
you talk about chairs tv cameras
cabinets
tables why they're functional they're
objects right they're tools
they're tools they're things you can use
normally when you're going from point a
to point b
you divide up the world into things you
can use those are things you see
your perceptual systems do this things
you can use
and things that might get in the way and
as you move from motivated world to
motivated world the little stories that
you inhabit you chop the world up in
different pieces
so a piano for a concert pianist is
different as a different phenomena than
a piano for someone who has no musical
education
but you're always parsing up the world
in terms of what it's good for
how it can serve your purposes and you
even see it that way
now the question is the complicated
question isn't so much
how do you parse up the world into
things that are useful to you like
chairs
the complicated question is what do you
do
when something that you don't expect
happens
so imagine you've had a 15-year long
marriage
and you find lipstick on your
husband's collar not once but three
times
and then you think well i thought i had
a map
right i thought we were both in the same
game
i thought we were both going from point
a to the same point b i thought we had
established a shared
structure of interpretation but i find
that there's some
aspect of his apparent behavior that's
completely outside
my scope of interpretation what do you
do well you can choose to ignore that
right it's easy to do that why would you
not why would you ignore it
because if you don't ignore it you have
to think he's not who i thought he was
and that's really not a good thing to
think because people are really really
really complicated and if they're not
who you think they are
you have no idea who they might be and
you also might think
well maybe i'm not who i think i am
because after all i got
sucked into this situation i thought i'd
pretty much
understood the world and turns out that
i certainly don't understand
the opposite gender and there's some
indication that i really don't even
understand myself because
fundamentally i'm so clueless and then
you might think well
when did this start this cluelessness
how long have i been blind
well do you really want to ask that
question well not generally right
it's easier to keep the dragon in the
closet which is where it tends to live
what happens when you encounter
something you don't expect
for a long time psychologists thought
that people learned fear
right so your typical person your
typical lab rat
was a calm creature now it's a funny
thing and because if you take a lab rat
out of his home cage and you put him in
a new cage where you want to teach him
say to be afraid of something to be
afraid of a light paired with a shock
which is a typical psychological
experiment
the funny thing about the rat is you got
to let him calm down before he's
normal well except that you might think
that the not
calm rat is also the normal route right
you take the rat out of this cage and
you put him in the new cage and what
does he do
he goes like this why well he's a rat
right someone might eat him so he's a
bit nervous about being in this new
situation
rats do not like being in new situations
they don't like bright light
if you put them in a new situation
that's brightly lit they go right over
to the corner
because they think maybe cats won't find
them rats are so afraid of cats that
they never even have to meet a cat to be
afraid of them so you can take a rat
that's never seen a cat in his life and
if you let him smell some cat odor or
show him a cat
he'll well i'll tell you if you show a
rat
a cat somewhere he doesn't expect it he
will run back to his burrow
and scream for 24 hours
now you imagine how scared you'd have to
be to scream for 24 hours especially
given a rat only lives about a year
so that would be for you like screaming
i'll be like screaming for three months
right so the rat runs back to his burrow
and he screams and every other rat who
hears him scream freezes
and they all stay like that for 24 hours
till they sort of calm down and then the
first thing they do is they go back to
the place where they saw the cat
and they start to map it out so they do
these things called corner runs which is
so the rat wants to go back to this
territory knows the territory might be a
place where he gets food
is the cat still there well you might
think stay in the borough right but then
maybe you don't get something to eat
so the rat goes back to the place where
the cat was carefully
and then he hunches down and he runs
over part of it and if nothing kills him
then he goes back and does the same
thing with a little more of the
territory until finally the rats have
run all over the territory again
then they go back to eating making love
paying attention to their families
because rats are quite social despite
the fact that they're rats
the rat smart enough to go back to the
scene of the crime so to speak right
it's not going to let the dragon that
might be there grow
the rat knows that if something is
terrifying it should be investigated not
run away from
the question is what do you encounter
when you encounter something you don't
expect and so you say well you've got
your spouse mapped out right but then
they do something you don't expect
which hopefully happens fairly regularly
right because otherwise you get bored
with them
they do something you don't expect and
you think haha
who is that person precisely and what
that means is that what
what that means is that when you
encounter something unexpected
you actually can't see what's there why
because it's too complicated you might
have to spend
a month talking to your spouse to figure
out just exactly why they have that
particular peculiar opinion
you have to explore and dig to find out
how they map the world
if you encounter something unexpected
the first thing you see is not the world
the first thing you see is just a sense
of
discomfort and fear combined with some
latent curiosity
that the world is not the way you
thought it was
now how do you find out what the world
is actually like
we have to investigate it you have to
investigate it means you have to
take a risk you have to move forward the
same way that people do in psychotherapy
you have to find the thing that you're
bordering on avoiding
and going and map it now it's a curious
thing you know
common anxiety disorder is agrophobia
agrophobia
is a generalized anxiety disorder and
people who suffer
severely from agrophobia often get to
the point where
because of their panics they're
housebound they can't go outside their
room
or their house now they'd run away from
the room or their house too if they
could but
there's nowhere to run so they're pretty
much stuck being somewhere
so an agrophobic comes in for therapy
i think well what do you do with them
and you say well then agrophobic says i
can't go on elevators
and you say okay well let's go try and
you say all right well
relax just teach the person to breathe
which really doesn't help that much but
it makes them feel better
you can do this without teaching them to
relax it doesn't matter a bit but it
does help them feel better
you say okay well there's the elevator i
said how close can you get to the
elevator
say well you know i can't really get
more than like 20 feet that's maximum i
said okay let's just go up to 20 feet
there and
let me do that and then you let them
stand there and stand there and stand
there and stand there and stand there
sooner or later they get bored
of being 20 feet from the elevator and
then you say well
look you know let's could you go 10 feet
no i couldn't go 10 feet
that's too close how about could you go
three more feet
yeah i think i could do that so they go
three more feet and then you let them
stand there
and they find out nothing terrible is
happening sooner or later
and then they go another three feet and
then they go another three feet and then
they're
they're like confronting the elevator
and then they're inside the elevator but
they're going like this
because they don't want to look at the
elevator right so you say well you got
to look at the elevator you look at the
numbers you can look at the buttons
so they do that then you think well
could we go up a floor no
we couldn't go up the floor okay well
i'll tell you what we'll just
close the door i'll put my hand and
it'll open again could you do that yeah
i could do that
step by step sooner or later and usually
sooner bang they've gone up a floor
right
so then what happens they go home and
have a fight with her husband that's
been brewing for like 15 years
why well it's not because the elevator
is symbolically related to the fight
has nothing to do with it it's because
what the person learns in
the combat with the unknown which just
happens to be taking the guys of an
elevator
is that they can confront things that
frighten them without being destroyed by
the confrontation
and so what you see immediately and this
was contrary to an original
psychoanalytic prediction is that
man you know you take that person out
you teach them they can go on the
elevator
and right off the bat they're going to
shopping malls they're in taxis they're
back in the subway
and they're standing up for themselves
at home generalization
why because they didn't learn that the
elevator wasn't frightening
that isn't what they learned they
learned that despite the fact that the
elevator was as terrifying as anything
they've ever encountered
they were actually up to the challenge
and now that's a really useful thing to
teach someone right because
if you have an obsessive compulsive
patient i had one who actually used to
work with radiation now he was
tara he worked in a some kind of bio lab
in montreal
people with obsessive compulsive
disorder often very frightened that
they'll contaminate someone else so like
typical obsessive compulsive obsession
would be i'll go to a shopping market
i'll touch some fruit from you know some
third world country
i'll get some nasty bacterial disease
i'll bring it home and i'll give it to
my kids
well you tell them look you know the
chances of that are like 150 000.
when they look at you and they think i
don't care if the chances are only 150
000 what if my kids die and you think
well yeah that does
pose a problem doesn't it because it
isn't exactly clear from a logical
perspective
where you should draw the risk lying
with the obsessive compulsive you do
exactly the same thing you say look yeah
your fear is real no kidding because
lurking at the bottom of their
fear is the same fear that everybody
else has right same
fear i might die i might get sick
i might lose the people that i love not
only might that happen
it's going to happen why aren't people
afraid of that all the time
we don't really know obsessive person
becomes aware of it
what do you tell them you say do it
anyway do it anyways
and they learn quickly that if they
don't run away from the thing they're
afraid of
there's something in them that responds
to it they learn that
the fear is not larger than they are
now i like edna foa's case in particular
because you always might wonder with
this like what's the limit right okay
yeah that sounds good in theory but what
if something really terrible has
happened to you
well what's happened to edna foe's
patience that's up there and with
terrible right i mean that's up there
with terrible
right stripped of social dignity
violated
physically that combines two of people's
most
specific fears well then there's other
kinds of
confrontation to it i like the story of
solzhenits and i think it's really a
good one because there's different kinds
of dragons right there's natural dragons
like
death and disease and then there's
social dragons like bureaucracies and
tyrannies
alexander solzhenitsyn you may or may
not know was a prisoner in the
soviet gulag concentration camp system
that by his report at least killed 60
million people between 1919 and 1959
right 60 million that's 10 times as many
as hitler killed
at least with regards to the genocide 60
million people
soldier nits and he had a pretty nasty
life i mean first of all he's on the
russian front
which was a nasty place to be then he
was captured by the germans and they
didn't like russians
so they put them in separate prisoners
of war camp partly because stellan who
was a consummate paranoid
wouldn't sign the geneva convention on
the treatment of prisoners of war
so the germans set up extra pow camps
for the russians
and they starved generally so badly that
if other pows were in the vicinity
they'd throw food packages over the
wire even though they themselves weren't
particularly well fed
so then so the war ends and the russians
win and socialism goes back to russia
right and what happens he's thinking you
know wow this is over
we helped defend the fatherland we're
going to get if not a hero's welcome at
least some welcome but stellen figured
no no
these russians who'd been to the west
they were contaminated by their exposure
to the western economic system
and as a consequence of that they posed
a threat to the integrity of the soviet
state
so he just threw them all in
concentration camps so
fine so sergeant is sitting there in
this concentration camp on a coal
pile a coal pile which contained this
kind of clay that his
compatriots would eat because they were
so damn hungry that it was better to
have the clay in their stomach than
nothing at all
and he thought all right
what the hell did i do to get here which
is really a remarkable thing to think
right because like there was the second
world war
and that probably couldn't be pinned
directly on him
and then there's stellan who was you
know really one of the world's worst
monsters
and then there's the concentration camp
and the p.o.w camp and like
a lot of things happened to solzhenitsyn
but he said he had nothing
but time to think in this concentration
camp and he wasn't really that happy
with the way things turned out so he
made a
vow in the camp and the vow was this he
said
he's going to go back over his whole
life whole life right from day one
and try to remember every time he ever
did something
he thought was wrong he thought right
not someone else but that
that gave his conscience a pang
and he said well since i don't have
anything better to do i'm going to spend
like the next 10 years seeing if i can
undo all those little knots in my soul
that i tied
and the consequence of that was that he
wrote a book called the gulag
archipelago right three volume book
1900 pages long he memorized it because
there wasn't any paper and pencil
available for him in prison
and then it circulated in the
underground in the soviet union for
years before it got published in the
west published in 1975
definitely one of the literary events
that brought down the soviet union
i think that's kind of interesting isn't
it think this one guy right
he's got numbers tattooed on his arm
he's as skinny as a rail he's three
quarters dead he's been beat to death in
15 different ways
he decides under completely unreasonable
circumstances that he's going to take
personal responsibility for the position
that he happens to find himself in
the consequence of that 25 years later
is that solzhenitsyn's still around but
the soviet union isn't
and you think well that can't be the way
the world works now can it but then you
think this too like
do we really know how the world works
right we've had a pretty nasty century
in the last hundred years
right we had the nazis we had mao
zeitung we had the recent tragedies in
africa we don't seem to learn anything
about genocide
someone like soznets and says well you
know
it might be your fault why
what are you ignoring good question can
you make peace with your own family
it's not so easy right it's probably no
easier than making peace between the
israelis and the palestinians
what do we encounter when we encounter
something we don't understand
we don't know it's not the simple world
of objects
the simple world of objects is something
we've learned to see the real world
is way more complicated than what we
just see
let me give you an example
when i was in montreal in 1985 my
computer crashed
so what do you do when your computer
crashes well when i when the computer
encounters something unexpected it
crashes it can't do a damn thing about
it you have to fix it
so i checked the monitor it was okay i
wouldn't go on
seemed all right and i noticed my lamps
weren't working so i went to the fuse
box so all the fuses seemed okay so then
i went outside
to go down to the corner store to get a
cigarette and i saw that outside all the
lights were off the traffic lights were
off right the whole city was in darkness
then i found out the next day that there
was a solar wind
big solar flare put out a big cloud of
electrons
zipped along to earth at the speed of
light put an electrical
pulse through the hydroelectric grid in
quebec crashed my computer
well i hadn't thought until that point
that the integrity of my computer was
dependent on the stability of the sun
everything is way more complicated than
it looks and when you just
look at something you see a very simple
representation of what's actually there
what do you encounter when you encounter
something unexpected
well when you first encounter it you
don't know
all you know is that it frightens you
but it makes you curious think dragons
right
every primates afraid of lizards
including us
chimpanzees don't like snakes if you
take a chimp it's never seen a snake you
throw to
show it a snake it will hit the roof of
its cage
then it'll look at the snake why would a
dragon hoard gold
because a dragon represents everything
that you're afraid of
what's embedded in everything that
you're afraid of
absolutely everything that you need to
find run from what you're afraid of
run from exactly what you need to find
one of the oldest dramatic
representations we know of not this
specific painting this is saint george
and the dragon right
dragon lives in the ground
chased there by heroes of a previous
generation
now and then re-emerging kills people
right these are skulls around its
lair threatens the integrity of the
community
like everything unexpected does
hero comes out
slays the dragon
frees the treasure in this case it's a
virginal woman
dragons hoard gold because the thing you
most need is always to be found
where you least want to look
i'm going to close this with another
dream
this is a dream my five-year-old nephew
had
now you got to get the context of this
dream right year after this dream
parents were divorced
so there were dragons in the house
he was about four at this time he's
running around the house with this
little plastic knight helmet on and a
sword is zipping around killing things
with it
doing this all the time and even when he
went to sleep at night he'd put this
the uh sword by his pillow and the night
helmet on his pillow
now every night or every second night or
every third night for six months he'd
been waking up
screaming now why well he was about to
go to kindergarten right so that's
that's a real threshold for a kid
away from maternal dependence
fundamentally into the real world that's
that's a new thing but also there was
upset in his house
so i was there one night when he woke up
screaming next morning i said
well did you dream anything and so he
launched into this story
he said dwarf
he was in this field and these little
creatures
like dwarves were coming up to him and
they didn't have any arms they just had
legs
and they were they had big beaks and
they were covered with hair and grease
and on top of their head was a cross
shaved into this
hair and there's lots and lots of these
dwarfs and they were jumping on them
with their beaks biting them
we all looked at him thought well it's
no wonder you're waking up screaming
right i mean you know that doesn't sound
so good and then he said well wait
there's more
right back in the distance there's a
dragon
and the dragon is puffing out fire and
smoke
and every time he puffs out fire and
smoke it turns into these dwarfs
big problem right just like the problem
with the hydra in greek mythology
cut off one head seven more up here
right so what are you gonna do about
these dwarfs kill one
big deal 10 more are coming
i said what can you do about that now
in a legal trial that would have been an
inadmissible question right
that's called leading the witness
because what i told him was
despite the horror of this situation
you maybe could do something about it
and he said ha
i take my sword i get my dad that's a
good idea right dad
there's the real dad and then there's
the tradition dad right you might as
well have your father by your side if
you're going to go into battle
i take my sword i get my dad i'd go to
where the dragon was
i jump up on his head i'd poke both of
his eyes out with the sword
i'd go down his throat to the place
where the fire comes out
i'd cut a piece of that box out and i'd
use it as a shield
and i thought wow that's unbelievable
unbelievable that he could do that it's
perfect right there's no sense going
after the dwarfs because
thousands of them you might as well go
after the dragon
what happens if you go after the dragon
you get a piece of it
right a piece of its center nature a
piece that can defend you against
anything including other dragons so
what if this was the case i think
evolutionarily speaking or religiously
speaking
what if we were adapted to the world and
what if it's not the
simple place of dead objects that we
think it is what if
it's something a lot more alive a lot
more like a story
what if the story is something like this
you have absolutely everything you need
but you have to use all of it if you run
away from
any of it and in particular the parts of
it that frighten you which
you know there's endless reasons to run
away from if you run away from
any of it you don't get that piece of
the dragon
if you miss even one piece there's a
[ __ ] in your armor there's a place
where you're vulnerable
if you make even one mistake you lessen
yourself
if you lessen yourself you're going to
run away more
not only that when someone wants to lean
on you they're not going to be able to
lean on you because you'll just fall
over
what if it was the case that we were
adapted to the world
really adapted to it so that if we made
full use of all the talents we had
we'd be okay what if it was the case
that
if we set out consciously
to never run away from something we know
we shouldn't run away from
that everything would be all right well
you can think whatever you want to think
but this is what i think
i think it's bloody amazing that that
little kids book that i read you at the
beginning of this lecture
had all that information in it and so
you might ask yourself when you leave
if that information isn't true how the
hell did it get there
that's it
you